دائما اخر المستجدات قصف اسرائيلي مستمر
ومتواصل على كافه مناطق قطاع غزه وربما
المنطقه الوسطى التي ن التي نتواجد فيها
هي التي تشهد الغارات الاعنف القصف الاعنف
خلال هذه الايام لا سما وان الجيش
الاسرائيلي بدا عمليه بريه انطلاقا من
مخيم البريج في وسط قطاع غزه وبالتالي
القصف بات عنيفا ومركزا الغارات لا تتوقف
ولا لحظه واحده على هذه المناطق وهذه
المخيمات التابعه للاجئين الفلسطينيين هي
مخيمات مكتظه المنازل فيها متلاصقه الجيش
الاسرائيلي عندما يقصف ويستهدف منزلا
معينا فان عشرات من المنازل تتضرر وتدمر
ويطال الدمار الكبير جراء هذه الغارات
الاسرائيليه ب على هذه المخيمات القصف
الاعنف ربما شهدته منذ الليله الماضيه
شهده مخيم المغازي في وسط القطاع و قبل
قليل اعلن عن استشهاد الوزير السابق وخطيب
المسجد الاقصى سابقا الشيخ يوسف جمعه
سلامه وهو واحد اعمده قطاع غزه وا الداعي
الاسلامي المعروف في
كافه المدن والدول العربيه والاسلاميه وهو
الذي كان وزيرا للاوقاف الفلسطينيه وايضا
خطيبا للمسجد الاقصى وله العديد من
المؤلفات وكان داعيه اسلاميه لكن رغم ذلك
الجيش الاسرائيلي استهدف منزله بعدد من
القذائف استشهد على اثر هذه الاصابه التي
حدثت من جراء سقوط هذه القذائف على منزله
ومخ ومنزله يقع في مخيم المغازي الذي شهد
ايضا عشرات من المنازل استهدفتها المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه وايضا الغارات الاسرائيليه
وعلى جراء ذلك كان هناك نحو 64 شهيدا من
جراء هذه العمليات التي ما زالت مستمره
والتي تواجه ايضا سيارات الاسعاف وسيارات
الدفاع المدني صعوبه في الوصول الى تلك
المناطق في هذا المخيم لا سما وان الجيش
الاسرائيلي استهدف المداخل الخاصه ب مخيم
المغازي وايضا استهدف الطريق المؤديه ما
بين مخيم المغازي ومخيم البريج وبالتالي
هناك صعوبه كبيره في الدخول الى المخيم
وانتشال الجثامين واجلاء الجرحى وايضا في
ظل القصف المستمر من قبل المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه فبكل تاكيد هناك خطوره لتحرك
سيارات الاسعاف وسيارات الدفاع المدني في
تلك المناطق ايضا حتى الان لا يمكن
لسيارات الدفاع المدني وسياره الاسعاف
الدخول لمخيم البريج وهو ايضا الذي تعرضت
مداخله و طرق الطرق المؤديه الى مخيم
البريج للاستهداف من الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه وايضا ما بين الفينه والاخرى
يتعرض الى قصف مدفعي عنيف من قبل المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه المتمركزه على الحدود الشرقيه
ربما لم تتوقف المدفعيه عن قصف كافه
المناطق الشرقيه ولا لحظه واحده ما بين
الفينه والاخرى نسمع اصوات انفجارات ناجمه
عن قصف هذه المدفعيه للمناطق الشرقيه قصفت
ايضا المناطق الشرقيه لدير البلح وسط
القطاع وايضا المناطق الشماليه لمخيم
النصيرات منطقه المغرا ومنطقه مدينه
الزهراء ايضا ارض المفتي في مخيم النصيرات
تتعرض ما بين الفينه والاخرى الى قصف
مدفعي عنيف من قبل المدفعيه الاسرائيليه
الطائرات ايضا شنت عده غارات استهدفت
منازل وايضا نفذت احزمه ناريه في مخيم
المغازي وفي مناطق مختلفه من مخيم المغازي
بالاضافه ايضا الى الغارات التي شنتها
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه في خانيونس
في المناطق الشرقيه لخان يونس ايضا منطقه
خزاعه وهي تقع في المناطق الشرقيه لخان
يونس تتعرض في هذه اللحظات الى قصف عنيف
من المدفعيه الاسرائيليه الطائرات الحربيه
قصفت منزلا وهناك عدد من الشهداء والجرحى
كذلك في هذه المنطقه بالاضافه الى ان هذه
المنطقه منطقه محاصره مناطق عبسان وخزاعه
والقرار هي مناطق محاصره لا تستطيع لا
سياره اسعاف ولا سياره دفاع مدني ولا حتى
المواطنين الخروج او الدخول الى هذه
المنطقه بفعل الغارات الاسرائيليه المركزه
عليها وبفعل القصف المدفعي العنيف على تلك
المناطق في ظل استمرار حصارها من قبل
الدبابات الاسرائيليه التي باتت تتواجد
على شارع صلاح الدين وتقصد بعنف ايضا
المناطق في وسط مدينه خانيونس وايضا وصلت
هذه القذائف الى مدرسه تابعه لوكاله الغوث
ونقل عدد من الاصابات والجرحى ايضا
المناطق الشرقيه لرفع تتعرض الى قصف عنيف
من المدفعيه وكذلك المناطق في غرب مدينه
رفح تعرضت الى قصف من الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه هذا الوضع في الجنوب لكنه لا
يختلف كثيرا عن الوضع في الشمال مدينه غزه
وشمال القطاع ايضا يتعرضان الى قصف عنيف
من الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه قبل قليل
ابلغنا عن غاره على منزل في حي الصبره في
مدينه غزه ونقل عدد من الشهداء والجرحى
الى المستشفى وكذلك ما زال هناك عشرات من
المفقودين تحت الانقاض لكن لا تستطيع
طواقم الدفاع المدني انتشالهم في ظل ايضا
تدمير الجيش الاسرائيلي للعديد من الاليات
في مدينه غزه في ظل القصف العنيف الذي
تعرضت له المدينه واباده احياء باكملها في
تلك المنطقه وبالتالي الدخول اصلا الى هذه
المناطق بات مستحيلا في ظل تدمير الجيش
الاسرائيلي للطرقات ولبنى التحتيه
وبالتالي التحرك في مدينه غزه هو ايضا صعب
للغايه بالاضافه الى استمرار القصف
الاسرائيلي